all right what do we got here oh um this  is fairly embarrassing for a guy like me  you grew up reading comic books he's got  to be Hulk gloves right all right open  some stuff here  oh it's perfume this is a chris Christie  cologne you know that smell anywhere all  right this is uh this is a ceramic  recreation of the aliens from arrival  here this is saying all the kids are  wearing it's called Eric Trump's tear  because he's not a manga mmm write this  I will say whatever it is is disgusting  to pick up  I keep leave just found this this is  what was in my dream of my bathtub when  I was a single man living in New York  City kept it for the whole eight years  then I met a woman gummy worms  okay no real idea here you go this is a  foot this is the gladiator sandal  Russell Crowe wore on set piece of  Hollywood history the leaf is a maple  leaf remember kids you too can learn  what things feel like if you just go  through life with your eyes closed  [Music]